The Human Experience is so fascinating
to me
but what's the point of it
I know that's kind of a really broad
question but what is the point it's not
broad it's a very narrow question okay
good what you're asking is what's the
point of life yeah
such a question comes because in some
way it's become burdensome
if you are ecstatic you wouldn't ask
that question
isn't it
in a moment of great joy you don't ask
that question right you ask that
question because somewhere your feet are
dragging because you don't have the
throttle under your right foot anymore
good one really good one
driving at the speed limit you feeling
what is the point of life
[Laughter]
but speed limits are there
on the regular Street when I first came
to United States
nearly 20 22 years ago
because I'm always used to putting the
throttle to the floorboard wherever I am
if the motorcycle is full on touching
the springs and sometimes cutting off
the Springs because it's it was never
enough
for me
this is a strange thing when I was
riding way back
about five times I cut off that brass uh
one pin will be there inside the
carburetors of a two-stroke engine at
that time we were riding two-stroke
engines
first time it happened I just couldn't
figure out what happened because if I
start the motorcycle it starts if I try
to throttle up it goes off
I took it to somebody who's kind of an
expert
he looked at it and he couldn't figure
it out
not knowing we thought the Dynamo is
gone so it's the Dynamo could be charged
those days only in the manufacturing
unit so we took it there one whole day I
sat there and got it charged and brought
it back still the same thing
then I realized it is something unheard
of the brass pin which is in the thing
when you throttle up it comes up and
there's a butterfly around it you know
that's how it was made so that has
gotten cut because I'm holding the
throttle full on like this
and after that it happened five times
then I knew every time it happened and
I've got I always started carrying one
extra pin with me
oh you are my Guru
so when in some way you don't live your
life joyfully enough intensely enough
you wonder what is the point of my
existence
because human intelligence is made this
way if it doesn't figure out
if it doesn't figure out all aspects of
life it will feel incomplete
if you had the brains of an earthworm or
a grasshopper you would be fine eating
sleeping reproducing and dying one day
but once you come with this level of
intelligence and awareness you have to
look deeper into your life because your
life is not fixed like their life nature
has drawn two lines for all of them they
just have to live within that and go for
you there are no lines this freedom is
what everybody is suffering
so some people try to go beyond Lines by
sitting in a race car some people do it
by doing crime some people do it by
doing adventure yes you see crime yes
that is in a way to break lines you need
to understand because I've I've worked
uh with uh you know like we have a
program called enough freedom for
imprisoned which is mandatory in all
Southern Indian prisons now and also we
did programs here in Kentucky in
Pennsylvania Tennessee and other areas
in the prisons
I have spent so much time with hardcore
criminals doing these programs what I
saw was this is their way of racing huh
breaking speed limits your way of doing
it is you went to the track if you did
the same thing on the street you would
be in the prison yes so they didn't get
sponsored they didn't get a car they
didn't get a machine they didn't get a
situation in their life where they could
create a race is a controlled uh
situation to commit crime
as far as a local Trooper is concerned
I'm saying yeah yes yeah it's a
controlled atmosphere where it's made
reasonably safe for everybody the risk
is only for those who want who have that
Madness in them but if you do it on the
street the risk is for everybody so it
becomes a crime but it's the same thing
if you have a high-powered car on the
street and you race when I first came to
United States
either what is the problem because I am
not I am never going to drive in such a
way it's going to be dangerous for
somebody else
but if I am not on the edge of danger I
can't live
okay so I'm like hitting it really full
throttle and people are saying you
should not drive like this in America
it's not like India you can drive at
your own speed first couple of visits
I'm here I'm driving I said what's the
problem there's power in the engine and
the road is wide open what is it no no
you can't do this they'll handcuff you
they'll do this I said why then I don't
listen to what others say I just observe
then I see
a 80 year old woman is driving a school
bus and going if I go whoosh
she may go fall off somewhere all right
so then I understood the speed limits
[Music]